[Music]
and welcome to the special edition of
hannity biden's afghanistan disaster now
for the hour we're going to review joe
biden's catastrophic withdrawal from
afghanistan leaving americans behind
enemy lines we'll cover the idiotic
planning the poor decision-making the
moral cowardice from a president who is
clearly not fit to lead this country
if there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out it's
easy to second guess we do take care of
our own that we leave nobody behind the
biden administration has managed that as
well as it can be managed under the
circumstances we were placed in it's
what america is all about it's about
pulling together
leaving nobody behind
couldn't this have been done and been
done in a more orderly manner i
respectfully disagree americans held
hostage abandoned behind enemy lines day
20.
all right day 20 americans held hostage
held behind enemy lines of the taliban
terrorists and tonight we begin in may
one month before the taliban's fighting
season now this was president trump's
deadline for withdrawal
now if and it's a big if the taliban if
they follow through with all of their
promises because they knew if they broke
any rules harmed any americans killed
any of our allies they knew under donald
trump the consequences they would be
dire and according to president trump no
matter what the united states would
maintain control of pogrom air force
base in perpetuity we built it we paid
for it we own it we're keeping it but
then came joe biden the self-proclaimed
foreign policy expert and his clueless
advisors arbitrarily pushing the
withdrawal date to august okay during
the peak taliban fighting season and
biden did nothing as the taliban
terrorists began what was a full-scale
assault on our afghan allies and they
began their march that led them to
taking control of kabul and that started
in april and then may and then june and
july and then august and instead of
fighting back at any point
and pushing back on the taliban and
holding them accountable as donald trump
said he would
and stop their advance biden ordered a
full-scale retreat abandoning base after
base in the middle of the night leaving
weapons and aircraft and military gear
important biometrics data behind all for
the taliban's taking he's now armed them
completely
in private joe biden knew that his
afghanistan policies well they were
rapidly collapsing but instead of being
honest with we the american people
instead of warning americans that were
there while we had control of kabul
warning our allies while we had control
and telling them uh we're gonna up
we're gonna speed up this withdrawal
leave immediately he goes on national tv
and said no everything is great one of
the best trained armies in the world he
promised that the afghan army was more
than capable of defending the country
that's what he said in july the same
month that he's going to tell oh that's
right the president of afghanistan to
lie look
is the taliban takeover of afghanistan
now inevitable no
it is not why
because you have the afghan troops have
300 000
well-equipped as well as equipped as any
army in the world
and an air force
against something like 75 000 taliban
it is not inevitable
none of that was true and we now know
joe biden knew it wasn't true joe biden
lied to you the american people right
there and we have the proof to show you
and now according to a leaked phone call
conversation and transcript from july
courtesy of reuters we know that joe
biden also encouraged the afghan
president to lie as well and change the
perception whether it's true or not uh
you need to just project a different
picture that all is great joe needed a
political win so perception was more
important than the reality that we all
know joe knew and the rest of the world
do and so in july while engaging and
encouraging ghani uh to change
perceptions biden abandoned bagram base
in the middle of the night in doing so
he left every american and every one of
our afghan allies in kabul totally
completely defenseless and in one month
the taliban easily marched to the
outskirts of afghanistan's capital city
not prepared to take control of such a
large city well washington post is now
telling us the taliban actually offered
not to invade kabul to let joe biden
keep it joe biden according to their
report said no no thanks the city is all
yours we'll just retreat just let us
have the airport and guess what the
perimeter around the airport that's
yours too but don't worry biden was
telling us the american people he
planned for every contingency he
promised the united states would not
leave any american behind he well he
said that over and over and over again
but you might remember this
the commitment holds to get everyone out
that in fact we can get out and everyone
should come out and that's the objective
that's what we're doing now that's the
path we're on and i think we'll get so
americans should understand that troops
might have to be there beyond august
31st no americans should understand that
we're going to try to get it done before
august 31 but if we don't the troops if
we don't we'll determine at the time
who's left
and
and if they're american forces if
there's american citizens left we're
going to stay to get them all out
we're going to stay till we get them all
out joe biden once again lying to the
american people the scene around the
airport it was horrific thousands of
people rushing to get in many trampled
to death many were beaten and gassed at
taliban checkpoints there were scenes of
babies being passed to u.s soldiers
mothers and fathers literally even
throwing them over walls with barbed
wire and razor wire it took hours
sometimes days for anyone to even get to
the airport gates and american citizens
those with american visas they were all
left to fend for themselves while other
countries like france the uk the dutch
they were sending special forces behind
enemy lines they were extracting their
citizens u.s forces were under strict
instructions not to leave the airport
walls as a result many americans turned
to private security agencies spending
tens of thousands of dollars to secure
safe passage to the airport make no
mistake there was no safe passage matter
of fact state department memos to people
in afghanistan said we cannot guarantee
your safety but you might want to make
your way to the airport how comforting
on thursday august the 26th a suicide
bomber detonated a massive bomb at the
gates of the airport that killed 13
brave u.s service men and women and more
than 150 others yes their blood is on
joe biden's hands because all of this
could easily have been prevented just
four days later all u s forces were gone
well now we have no diplomatic presence
on the ground in afghanistan we have no
embassy there we have limited intel
capabilities no security forces
whatsoever but there are still hundreds
maybe more than a thousand they don't
know the exact number of americans
trapped behind enemy lines hostages to
the whims of the taliban and probably
soon isis k and al qaeda thousands more
of our afghan allies yeah he signed
their death certificates and they remain
hopelessly trapped there is no way out
and now they're at the mercy of the
terrorists in the taliban and worse it
is the single worst foreign policy
failure in my lifetime
one of the worst in american history but
this week joe biden nope he had to
congratulate himself mission
accomplished job well done and goes on
to say it is an extraordinary success
the right the why is the best decision
really
take a look the extraordinary success of
this mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals
now some say
we should have started mass evacuation
sooner
and couldn't this have been done have
been done in a more orderly manner
i respectfully
disagree joe biden has failed this
country and we will never forget it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else